how did your deal with film buff come
about what they they contacted us I
think they'd seen or you know not that
read about the movie I think in either
the Arizona underground film festival
programme of the New Orleans horror film
festivals definitely I believe one of
the horror festivals and you know they
read about the movie and contact us
through their of say you know wanting to
see a screener of it just liking the
sound of it and then you know they may
have watched the trailer that was online
from there I assume and so wanted to
check it out why do you think they
acquired the film did they tell you did
they give you the pros and cons and they
did they tell you how they could sell it
yeah I'm certain I know we talked about
it with them when you know we first had
our conversations with them yeah I can't
remember you know I just be guessing at
this point but I think a lot of it is
the you know certainly the mix of comedy
and horror that they that the that felt
you know done in a unique way to them
you know and with you know a title like
dick night I suppose it was kind of
adding those elements of of of something
people might want to see do you think
your next film will be a horror comedy
or do you want to do something I right
now it's a comedy but yeah I don't know
that's not to say i wouldn't try to do
something with a horror element to it
but you know i don't think I'm you know
horror ideas aren't the ideas when I sit
down and I'm coming up with ideas for
moves they aren't the ones that
naturally you know are coming to me I
mean hina this previous one was really
based on this location that just kind of
had a idea built into it and so it
was
you know it was easy for me to to see
the horror in that I don't know that I I
see it yet you know as often he you know
outside of that
you